we call that the law of goya g-o-y-a get
off your ass you have a lot more time
than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem most procrastination by the
way is done because of low self-esteem
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's kevin carmichael and i am not a
morning person but when you start your
day with a powerful routine that
inspires you like watching one of these
videos it can change your life so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee know that i believe in you
and get ready for a shot of espresso
from john assaraf
[Music]
there was actually a very very big
mistake
in the movie the secret okay
and in the movie the secret
the
story that was told
was that all you have to do is think
believe in your heart
and you'll achieve it's not true
there's a lot of people who think
wonderful great thoughts
they believe that i deserve this and i
can have this
but they don't do one thing
and this is what causes their problem
you know what that one thing is you want
to know
they don't take consistent action every
day
so in the secret they didn't talk about
you have to do the right things
in the right order
at the right time
and they led a lot of people to believe
that all you have to do think about it
just think about it well i've never met
a monk in a monastery who's been praying
to make money
and through the ceiling a safe falls
with a million dollars i've never met
that yet
and but i have met a lot of people who
think and believe
and then they learn what they need to
learn
they upgrade their knowledge and their
skills they overcome their fears they
overcome their doubts they overcome
their lack of confidence they overcome
their lack of certainty and they take
action anyway
and then
little by little
things start to happen for them they
achieve the results and we call that the
law of goya g-o-y-a get off your ass
law of attraction uh it's my favorite
law of attraction and law of goya
together
that's what works
consistent action is the cure-all
whatever problem you have whatever issue
you're facing whatever big life you want
to create for yourself the way to get
there is not some giant
short burst of effort
it's the daily consistent grinding
action that will help you accomplish
your goals people look at my channel
and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history
it took so many years guys so many years
of just making content and not seen any
results
i took i forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get to almost 2 million
subscribers now sitting over 3 million
subscribers etc
i haven't missed
an upload
every single day
for i don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
i've made videos through
travel i've made videos through
elect electricity electricity outages
i made videos through breaking my neck
i made videos through my tour i made
videos through vacation i made videos i
made videos i made videos i made videos
i made videos on my videos and you can
plan you could prepare you can get ahead
you can
you can batch them
but i don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested
that's when you have to show yourself
what you're made of
even little things like
i remember filming at my dance studio in
toronto
and i had my camera guy and my assistant
and we're filming
and
the electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go i guess we can't film like the
first thing that
that my camera guy says is okay well i
guess we can't film i can't film with
this like electricity outage and then
fire alarm
fire alarm
like you can't film with that it's like
i'm
i'm filming today
so
i took my phone it was freezing outside
i took my phone went outside and just
started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
i've made videos with my broken neck
i broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and i
next week i'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
i'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos i'm wearing this giant
neck brace i got this giant scab here on
my forehead because i smashed my head
against the wall
when i fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck i'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
i still don't like being on stage i
still get nervous every single time
but i still have a message
and i still want to serve how does
somebody
like that
have this kind of channel
well because of every single day making
videos you've done over 10 000 videos
i've done over 10 000 videos that's
crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 plus videos
over
12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
i think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
you've guys you've had ideas you haven't
you've you have had an idea
that you loved you gave up on too soon
that if you just kept doing it this is
an idea that you had maybe three years
ago that if you just found a way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and i get
it i'm there too i'm i'm impatient i
want immediate results i want things to
happen i'm putting my best i want this
video right now to be the best one i've
ever done and i put my effort to try to
make that happen and i fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent
action
to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
i'm filming this on a tuesday
tuesday is my youtube day
i always film on tuesday i block it off
in my calendar
i just came back from vacation
and on the tuesday of my week i was
still making videos people say well
still work on vacation first off it's
not work like i like this this is fun
for me this isn't this isn't i have to
go make videos if that was my mindset i
would
i'd be out i wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody uh one of
the people that i invested into
yesterday is like how do i take a
vacation on my business
like how do i my wife wants to know how
do i go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working
it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have in the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional
most of your vacation time is not
intentional either if you were to spend
21 hours a day with your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're gonna
spend working
is easy as nothing
so of course you can take time off
but you have to put in your calendar you
have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen
because otherwise it's a dream i could
say i want to make youtube videos but if
it was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too
every
uh every afternoon
at 2 30 i spend time with nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning i take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we
we stay inside and just be together if
it's raining like we'll spend time every
day every week at 2 30 because i want i
wanted to spend more time with nina
during the week weekends we're basically
all in on on the relationship but the
weekdays can be crazy you know so we
spend time in the morning we spend time
in the evening and i wanted to spend
2 30
it's 25 minutes together but intentional
25 minutes that intentional 25 minutes
is worth more than three hours of just
sitting in front of a tv that's not time
together
you have a lot more time than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem
if you feel like you got the end of the
week and you were so busy but you got
nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
i'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip i'm a little jet
lagged
from coming out from the west i'm still
making videos i'm still
videos have to be made they're going up
like when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today i don't care
if i'm lying in bed i don't care
i don't care if i'm in the hospital i've
made videos from the hospital i don't
care where videos have to come up i
don't care if they're the best videos
the best
with what i can make right now
if i'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what i can make
right now if i'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what i can make
out of the hospital but i'm gonna make
the best of what i can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
on your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're gonna the next
day wake up say i'm not i can't do that
i'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more i follow through i
follow through i follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time you come up with
a goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay i'm
not gonna do it today every time you say
that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it
you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and so it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself
you're gonna make a hundred videos a day
every day
you're gonna make a thousand phone calls
a day every day
you're not you're gonna write a hundred
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not gonna
happen
make it a realistic plan something you
can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why i
create the espresso to be with you every
morning to give you the boost to bring
you people like john ashraf and oprah
and elon musk and these people who lift
you up who inspire you hopefully that's
the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams who are trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today i'm supposed to do that
the god i want to do that
what brings you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions
to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker when you commit to a plan
of action
of when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you hey
this john asref and do you love good
books i love to read because there's so
much wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research pay 15 20
bucks and you learn
so much now i'm reading this
awesome book called built to serve
find your purpose and become the leader
you were born to be and one of my new
friends really smart guy really great
guy who serves a lot of people evan
carmichael
um wrote it and um
i'm gonna read a little bit from
chapter number one
and um i love this piece and maybe it's
because i just watched uh the series on
tv on michael jordan the last dance
which is really great by the way also
but
one of the things he says here
is everybody has
michael jordan
talent
at something everybody has a michael
jordan talent at something
you just haven't found it yet
or
you have and you don't believe in
yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so
lots of pearls and gems and motivational
pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star
if you can self observe
then you can turn it outwards but it all
starts with being
self-observing awareness of when i'm
uncomfortable
how do i respond when i'm doubtful how
do i feel when i've got negative
self-talk going on
what's going on when i'm procrastinating
what am i fearful of what am i most
procrastination by the way is done
because of low self-esteem
if you knew how to get something done
you could do it highly effectively and
on time and you were loving it you can
do it but most people procrastinate
because they feel doubtful they don't
have all the information they're
procrastinating because they're worried
that if they don't do it perfectly
somebody's going to judge them cognitive
priming right so what's cognitive prime
so think about this when um a baby is
learning how to eat okay what does you
know
mommy or daddy do mommy or daddy you
know takes the spoon and you know she
puts it in the jar she pretends to eat
it herself and then she puts it into the
baby's mouth
open the mouth
and she does that to cue the baby's
brain of what to do so she pretends
she's doing it herself she gets the baby
to do it and through this repetition a
baby will learn
spoon in the hand
in the jar
spoon has food on it mommy's opening her
mouth she's bringing it to me open my
mouth i put the food in my mouth oh this
yummy thing feels so good
eat this food
and so if you think about what's
actually happening we're getting the
motor cortex of her brain going we're
getting her taste buds going you know at
a certain point we'll put the spoon in
her mouth and put her hand in the jar so
that she could do it for herself so
we're priming her through visual cues
through auditory cues through taste cues
right through all of the different
senses we're priming her brain and then
we're reinforcing it
day after day after day after day to
create the neural network the
connections in the brain that if i want
that yummy food in my mouth i have to
learn how to take the spoon in my hand
put it in the jar get it all over the
place initially until i could do it
without spilling it all over the place
well that takes you know weeks and
months and years to tie your shoes to
learn how to eat to learn how to brush
your teeth all these things that are
automatic now yes all the things that
are automatic now so before something's
automatic
it's not yeah and it can feel really
uncomfortable so so let's take um
[Music]
a disempowering belief that you have i'm
not good enough i'm not smart i'm too
young i'm too old i'm female i'm
whatever it is you have a disempowering
belief it's a nothing more than a
pattern in the brain so somehow
a pattern that wasn't there before
got there
right who told you that your parents
your teachers your brother your sister
uh your best friend said ah you'll never
like who did that it's really irrelevant
but if the pattern is there and it's a
dominant pattern because you've believed
it for 20 30 40 years whatever the case
might be
and it's been reinforced
what does brain sign say about how the
do i get rid of it
and it says well you'll never get rid of
it but you can deactivate it
okay
how do i deactivate it
right how do i deactivate it so every
time i catch myself saying i'm not good
enough or fill in the blank feel take
any limiting belief
and any time you catch yourself saying
it or feeling it
what if you said to yourself
stop
in the past i used to believe that and
now i believe i'm more than good enough
in the past i used to feel like i'm too
young but now i can use my age as a
benefit to achieve that goal
any limiting belief we can do one of a
couple things we can say in the past i
used to
and so what we're doing is we're not
saying no stop that we're not
reinforcing a limiting belief by trying
to fight it we acknowledge it's just a
pattern embracing it and just say in the
past i used to believe that and now
here's what i'm choosing to believe
so now what i'm doing is i'm taking an
existing neural pattern and i'm
changing the pattern i'm taking away its
energetic force by adding new words that
i'm choosing now versus the ones that
were given to me or the ones that i felt
when i was too young to actually change
it on my own then so now i'm paying
attention to my self-talk i'm paying
attention i'm paying attention to the
inner critic
a lot of times when we are focusing on
what we've lost
or what we're losing
we're not focusing on what we've gained
a lot of times we're focusing okay on
what's possible as a result of this
we we tend to mono focus right on either
good or bad i like it i don't like it it
tastes good it doesn't it's hurting me
it's not but what if you could learn how
to observe both
what if you could
observe the law of polarity in its
entirety that says you cannot have an
electron without a proton and in without
an out and up without a noun you cannot
have that on this planet in this
universe
so is it possible that with just a
little bit of training whether it's
mindfulness or meditation or awareness
you can be sad
you can grieve
and be joyful and happy at the same time
see it's when we are afraid that we're
losing something
that we've got that frankenstein brain
of ours saying what if what if what if
what if oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
when we are in that state
we can't be focused on what are we going
to do about it
now in a grieving state like with my
mother
um the only thing i want to do about is
make sure that we respect and honor her
life and my brothers and sisters and my
dad etc
so i need to focus on that
and when we're talking about
you know a business going under a
relationship you know that's unraveling
right now
if you're focusing on all of the
disempowering emotions and circumstances
you cannot
be focusing on the solution to that
possible problem
so you have to learn
how to manage the emotions and for those
who don't know what that's like i want
you to imagine i just got really mad
a hollywood actor or actress learns that
they are not their emotions they have
emotions
now everybody's going to grieve
differently
but i want people to understand that you
don't have to be disempowered
in grief
you can be empowered in grief
and everybody's going to do it
differently and some people are going to
go inside some will go outside but we
have the ability
to frame things in ways that empower us
and gives us the best chance to move
forward instead of being a victim of it
and all i'm saying is
consider consider that you have way more
power than you are displaying in your
emotional management in your focus in
your awareness
and in your behavior and you can feel
the entire spectrum of emotions totally
cool with that but are you being
constructive
versus destructive in your behaviors do
we have to develop trust and rapport
first if i don't trust you
and i don't have any rapport with you
i will not pay attention to your brand
so hey philip
right so i have to come up
with a way to build trust and rapport
first before i do anything else so
how can i how can you
build trust and rapport with people who
don't know you or like you or trust you
yet so how can you build trust and
rapport first
right how do you build trust and rapport
first
and the answer is
come on i'm reading all your comments
give away some of your expertise give
away some of your knowledge give away
some of your best stuff
thank you victor john give away
your your techniques your tools your
advice
and so here's my question for you how
can you and
ace mantra or as mantra how can you
give away
stuff to people who need what you have
so think about your brand
and ask yourself
the people who may want to buy my
products or my services my knowledge my
skills
what is it that i could give the people
that
need some help right now
so can you give them
tools tips techniques can you do q a
sessions to answer their questions can
you give them infographics can you give
them videos can you give them something
written can you give them something to
make them feel
like they
like you
trust you and they want maybe want to do
business with you so you have to make
let me just make sure i use the right
word
you have to create the environment
of trust and rapport i i do free
sessions every tuesday here
taking what i've learned over 40 years
of building companies over 40 years of
successes and failures over 40 years of
investing
millions of dollars whether it's in
marketing
uh hundreds of millions of dollars you
know in marketing and sales over 40
years um i give away a lot of free stuff
whether it's on my youtube channel on
linkedin on instagram um on facebook
wherever it is i give away a lot of free
stuff i was really fortunate when i was
19 years old i met a wonderful gentleman
who was very successful with his family
he was very successful giving to
charities he was very healthy he was
very
gentle and kind and when he started to
share with me to teach me that my entire
reality
was based on what i believed was real
and what i believed was true about
myself about what's possible
and that i could change that
that's when my life started to change
and he said if you start to change the
way you think
and you start to learn
every day for one hour to upgrade your
knowledge
and your skills
and then you take action every day
on the things that are the most
important instead of all the different
things that you can do
it says if you focus on doing three to
five things every day
towards your goals
he says in one year you'll be at a
totally different destination three
years
big distance
five ten years your life won't be the
same
and i was tired of living a mediocre to
less than mediocre life
and so i said listen
you seem to have a good plan and a good
path you're making millions of dollars
you're giving a lot of money to charity
you're happy you're healthy uh you've
got a great family i want that
he said if you want that follow the
blueprint
don't try to figure it out just follow
the blueprint
and that was another lesson that he
shared with me is that you don't have to
reinvent the wheel yes like if you want
to fly right now you don't have to
figure out how to fly you know there's
already a blueprint for how to generate
or create an airplane yeah so if you
want to be healthy there's already a
blueprint if you want to make more money
there's already a blueprint if you want
to buy real estate or the stock market
or start a business and grow a business
there's people before us
that have already got the blueprint and
all you have to do is paint paint the
numbers inside the box and then you can
use your creativity
so i just became a very good follower
for a long time of things that worked
and when you follow things that work
it's like having the combination to a
safe
if someone gives you the combination to
a safe and they tell you turn this way a
little bit this way a little bit turn
this way a little bit turn this way a
little bit then open it
you can have access to it but most
people
don't look for the combination
and then even when they get the
combination
they try it in the wrong order i was
born in tel aviv israel
and moved to montreal because my parents
were
tired of raising their kids in a worn
torn part of the world which was you
know in israel and the palestinian areas
i'm sure everybody felt that same way
that whole region my parents moved to
montreal
from
israel and at the time i really had a
hard time learning the french and the
english language
and i developed some
i guess self-esteem issues that i wasn't
smart enough or as good as the other
kids because i couldn't communicate
when i was really young and then i got
into a lot of trouble
uh as a
as a young teen from the age of 12 to 17
i got into a lot of trouble with the law
mostly because
i had low self-esteem if you can believe
that
i did at the time are you interested
in achieving that vision for your life
are you interested in achieving those
goals
or are you committed
are you interested or are you committed
and
i didn't know what the difference really
was at the time
and so i asked mr brown what's the
difference and he said to me says if
you're interested
you'll do what's convenient if you're
interested you'll use the fact that you
didn't like school and you didn't do
well in school to control your thinking
and your self-esteem he said if you're
interested you come up with stories and
excuses why you can't achieve those
goals and dreams that you shared with me
you come with stories and excuses as to
why you don't want to do the work
necessary to grow and to learn what you
need to learn
he says however
if you are committed
he says you will do whatever it takes
you will upgrade your knowledge you'll
upgrade your skills you'll become who
you need to become and you'll learn from
whoever you need to learn
to be able to
achieve those goals and dreams so
lesson number one
is no matter what goal or vision you
have
ask yourself that question okay are you
interested
in achieving that goal and dream
or are you really really
really committed and willing to do
whatever it takes when i was
19 years old okay
when i had a mentor a man who was in his
50s very very successful
he agreed to to mentor me and to teach
me what he knew
and so he sent me home
with some paper
and on the paper it said
what do you want to achieve in your
health
what do you want to achieve in your
relationships what do you want to
achieve financially
what do you want to achieve charity
what do you want to achieve as far as
experiences
when do you want to retire by how much
money do you want to make
how he asked me
about 10 pages of questions
and at 19
i had no idea
how much do i want to make i want to
make enough to pay my bills i want to
make enough to you know just eat well
and then have some fun i want to go
drinking with my friends i want to go
party and travel a little bit and pay
for my apartment than a nice car and
things like that
but he had me think you know one year
five years
25 years and i was 19. and he made me
write down
the answers to these questions even
though they were
i had no idea how to achieve them he
made me write it down it took me a whole
weekend
and i went back and he looked at my
papers
and so he looked at health and wealth
and relationships and career and
business and he goes
good way to do the exercise i'm very
proud of you he says now i want you to
increase that amount
and so i said that you know by the time
i was 45 i was 19
i said by the time i was 45
i was going to be a
millionaire nobody in my family
was a millionaire not my aunts not my
uncles not my cousins nobody in the area
that we lived in and i wrote that down
and he said no that's not enough he says
you could do better than that and i'm
like
i'm swallowing i'm scared i'm afraid
how am i going to become
more than that how can i
have all of this he says don't worry
about the how right now
you worry only and not even worry but
you write down what you want
[Music]
and so i went back home
and started to write again a game and
and took another you know half a day to
to redo my goals
and he said to me great now in order for
you
to achieve those goals
what do you have to believe
wow i said well i have to believe that i
can i have to believe that i deserve it
and even though i didn't believe that i
deserved it she said what would you
think you had to believe
i have to believe that it could be done
i have to believe that i could learn
the skills i would have to believe so he
made me write out what i would have to
believe good question
and then he said great what do you think
you would have to do every day
wow
an amazing question
well i guess i would have to come to
work every day and i'd have to really
get good at what i'm doing and i'd have
to learn more that i'm learning right
now because i hated to learn back then
and i'd have to
you know gain more skills which i didn't
have any
the only thing i was good at was i had
an easy time talking to people like i am
with you now
and he said great well
let's make a list of all of these things
and let's come up with a plan
to do this he said so every day let's
look at some beliefs
and so every day he would have me look
at my goals
and i would sit in my chair
and i'd have my goals you know that he
had me right
and i would take my fingers which he
told me to touch my goals so that i
would send a message to my brain as i
was reading it and seeing it to
reinforce
the goals that i wrote
then i would read
the beliefs
that i needed to have
i
have all the intelligence i need to
achieve these goals
i can now
acquire all the skills to achieve these
goals and i read about 20 or 30
different beliefs every day
and for the first month or two months
while i was reading all of this
in my head
this one word
kept coming up you know what the word
was
because as i would read it my brain
would say
that's not true
and he told me that my brain would try
to talk to me
and tell me it's not true and he said if
you keep doing it over and over and over
again
your brain's gonna get tired of telling
you it's not true
and especially if after you
do this you take some actions
to upgrade your knowledge upgrade your
skills
you'll develop more confidence and more
certainty
so he taught me
how to use the telephone
to make telephone calls to people
to see if they were interested in buying
a real estate property or selling their
home i was in real estate at 19.
and you know for the first month it was
hard second month it was hard the third
month it was hard but as i got better
and more comfortable at being on the
telephone talking to people that i
didn't know that i thought didn't want
to hear hear from me or talk to me
i found one person then two people then
three people then five people who said
yes
because as i became more comfortable as
i became more skilled as i gained more
knowledge
people received me differently
and in my first year i made thirty
thousand dollars i was nineteen
which was five thousand dollars more
than my father made as a taxi driver
[Music]
then he started to upgrade my skills a
little bit more and he started to teach
me some very specific
things to do in real estate
and in my second year at 20 i made 151
000 wow five times more income because
every day for one hour
one hour a day i practiced
my beliefs i practiced seeing my vision
i rehearsed it i got on the phone i
upgraded my knowledge i upgraded my
skills i love your story thank you and
and so he kept he kept directing me a
little bit at a time
to become more tomorrow
than i am today
and he said to me something that changed
my life
it says if you invest one hour a day
on your personal growth and changing who
you believe you are
that is the equivalent of nine
40 hour weeks
of effort
one hour day for a year
is nine 40 hour weeks
if you and i said today we're gonna
learn break dancing we're going to learn
knitting and we're going to spend 9
weeks 40 hours a week
we would get good at what painting we
would get good at at knitting we would
get good at darts we would get good at
playing a musical instrument if we were
committed to one hour a day
so i've practiced
one hour a day
for 32 years
and that one hour a day has changed my
life we all have these patterns
that are subconscious
that are driving our behaviors more than
our conscious efforts
and so
when
we're dealing with the gorilla
in the brain and again it's a
metaphorical way to look at it
you have to understand that the gorilla
is going to get whatever the gorilla is
wired to get the gorilla
does not care about what you consciously
want
the gorilla
really focuses on the patterns
that are going to keep it safe and
here's what safe means safe just means
comfort zone let's say you're miserable
let's say you're broke let's say you're
overweight let's say you're in a
relationship that you you don't like
let's say you're a job you don't love
that
is safe to the gorilla why because it
knows the pain it's already dealing with
it knows the discomfort it knows the
price it's paying already versus getting
out of that comfort zone leaving the job
that you're not happy with leaving a
relationship that you're not in love
with um
trying to earn more income getting out
of debt you could be in debt and
comfortable you could be in a
relationship you hate and comfortable
you can be in a job that you don't love
and comfortable and the gorilla is gonna
keep you in your comfort zone let's say
you have a fear of
public speaking
is it really a fear of public speaking
that you have
or is it a fear of getting up on stage
and being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
or
judged hmm
let me take you to another type of fear
being buried alive
can you imagine for just a moment if
there was an earthquake or there was a
natural disaster and somehow you were
buried
alive
wouldn't that trigger this crazy amount
of fear of dying while you were buried
alive now why am i taking you there i'm
taking you there because
fear is a subconscious trigger
whenever we feel threatened and the
threat could be a threat for our very
lives
and when that happens we move into one
of four
modalities and modality number one is we
try to fight this feeling number two is
we freeze because we're in such shock
number three
we may faint because of the
neurochemistry that the fear causes
or we might run away if we can run away
now these neurological reactions
are our brains way of keeping us safe
which is the highest need and desire of
the brain safety above all else
so when we are looking to achieve a goal
that we want to achieve
and it doesn't matter if it's you know
to start a business or grow your
business or leave a relationship that
you're not happy or a job that you're
miserable in
whenever we think about the actual
behavior that is required to achieve
that goal
once we get motivated in doing that
that's part one of how our brain works
but right after that our brain has to
analyze if there's any real or imagined
danger associated with taking that
action step so if you are going to leave
a relationship that you're not happy in
your brain is going to activate the
memory circuits and discover what's in
there that may have caused you pain and
suffering in the past
and when that happens
whether it's a relationship you want to
leave a job that you want to leave a
goal you want to achieve your brain is
always analyzing is there any danger
here and when there is real or imagined
danger
the amygdala part of the brain the
emotional response center in the brain
is going to fire off an amazing amount
of neurochemicals like cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine and it's
that rush of those neuro chemicals that
causes this emotion energy in motion we
label as fear
now
once you have that rush of
neurochemicals in your bloodstream that
actually gives you an enormous amount of
energy
but what most people never have learned
how to do is how to take that energy and
channel it to action versus the fighting
it freezing or running away when you
recognize a fear i want you to do this
it's called inner size number one it's
called take six calm the circuits
when fear neurochemicals are released in
your brain you've activated the fear or
stress response center in the brain
when you just observe
the emotion called fear through being
quiet
and breathing six times in through your
nose and out through your mouth like
this you take a deep breath in for five
seconds
[Music]
you blow out like you're blowing out
through a straw and if you do this five
seconds in five seconds out five seconds
in five seconds out with six to ten
breaths
you're going to deactivate the fear
response center
and that actually is going to reactivate
your thinking center in your brain so
that you can move on to inner size
number two inner size number one is take
six com the circuits inner size number
two is called ayah a
i a and that stands for awareness
intention
action so here's how you do this after
you do the first exercise then you move
to inner size number two and then you
ask yourself in a calm relaxed state
what am i thinking right now
what am i feeling right now am i calm or
am i tense am i breathing
deeply or shallow is my heartbeat fast
or slow
and in this state of calm awareness
as you deactivate the brain's fear or
stress response
you can observe
what you are feeling and what you are
thinking and what you were doing
and then
you can ask yourself the next question
that is the i what is my intention right
now is my intention
to move forward or is my intention to
stay in this fearful state and chances
are you say well i really want to move
forward
and then you ask yourself what is one
action step that i can take
to move forward towards my goal and
dream so this is how it works after you
do the inner size number one
to calm the circuits and to deactivate
the reactive state that fear causes and
then you move into the second exercise
called ayah to move into the responsive
state
awareness intention action
now puts you in control of being aware
of the fear
being aware okay of what you've been
thinking and then being at choice of
what you want to do so when you combine
these two inner sizes you are now
reconfiguring the neural network in your
brain around the goal that you want to
achieve and instead of allowing the real
or imagined danger to control you to
stop you dead on your tracks
you take one action step in a calm state
and that rewires your brain so that the
same reaction doesn't hold you back
anymore and that you are now able to use
fear as your fuel for success
is your financial governor
holding you back from doubling or
tripling your income in the next six to
12 months
now you may be asking john what in the
world is a financial governor and i'll
explain it this way
many years ago when the car companies
were building engines that were faster
and stronger and more resilient
cars could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour but
because of laws in europe and the in the
united states these governors were put
on the engine so that the car even
though it can go faster and perform even
better
it was limited to about 155 miles per
hour
so here we are we have these cars that
can go extremely fast but for obvious
reasons to conserve on gas to be able to
have more safety on the roads and to
keep us generally all driving around the
same speed limit we created these
governors to put on engines in order to
limit the speed at which the car can go
at well what does that have to do with
you earning more money you accumulating
more wealth and the answer is everything
if you understand that you have a
conscious brain that wants to set goals
but you have a subconscious mind that is
going to limit your thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors to what you are
governed by which is your subconscious
mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
people who make thirty thousand dollars
a year or fifty or a hundred or five
hundred thousand dollars a year or a
million dollars a year or more
their financial governor is set at a
totally different setting than somebody
who's earning less so why does this make
a difference well it makes a difference
because there's a part of your brain
that chooses the goal that you want to
achieve and there's another part of your
brain that's responsible for everything
else your thoughts emotions feelings and
behaviors and so
if you don't have coherence between
these two parts of your brain if you
don't know how to remove the governor
and reset it
chances are you're going to have goals
and dreams financial ones and even
lifestyle ones that you're not going to
achieve not because you're not capable
of doing it it's just because you are
wired set conditioned programmed
whatever you want to call it to earn the
income you're earning right now and
maybe a little bit more each day each
week each month versus doubling or
tripler quintupling your income now let
me give you a different visual for this
that'll hopefully
cement what i mean let's say
you're in a room that has a thermostat
in there and the thermostat is set to a
nice and comfortable 70 degrees and you
feel nice at that temperature what
happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter and cold air comes
in
well what happens is the mechanism in
the thermostat that picks up what the
temperature is in the room picks up a
deviation that cold air has come in the
room and what does it do it sends a
signal through the electrical system for
the heater to go on
so that the room gets back to 70 degrees
that's called a cybernetic mechanism a
control and respond mechanism that
occurs in machines that we create them
in or in animals like us
so whether it's hot air coming into a
room or cold air coming into a room any
deviation from the set program
activates the air conditioning or the
heat until the program and the room are
one and the same
that is a cybernetic mechanism as i
mentioned and here's what happens in us
humans if you're used to earning thirty
thousand or fifty thousand seventy five
a hundred or two hundred or more or you
are used to a certain lifestyle any
deviation up or down from that setting
that comfort zone that programming
kicks in your nervous system so that you
either
turn up the jets and earn more based on
what you're used to or if you do really
well for a week a month a quarter you
actually back off and sabotage your
success until you meet the setting that
you have in your mind that is how a
governor works in a car that's how a
governor works in your brain so
if you want to double or triple your
income in the next six months 12 months
two years
doesn't it make sense
that you should reset your financial
governor the expectation point the
programming the conditioning
well of course it does
what i've seen
in my years of training whether it's
sales people or entrepreneurs or
individuals to make more money is the
ones that think that they could do it
just by gaining more knowledge
missed the point because as a part of
our brain that gains more knowledge but
doesn't change behavior what you have to
do is reprogram your financial set point
your conditioning the expectation point
and when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your subconscious programming
that is when your behavior starts to
change that is when fears dissipate that
is when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired action
and you don't sabotage the success that
you are achieving so
in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset your governor
reset your financial thermostat the
fascination that i have is um
around living in a world right now where
we have access to
all the how to
how do i make more money how do i grow
my business how do i have a great
relationship how do i you know find the
love of my life how do i put a rocket
ship on mars
and
a lot of people are confusing having
information and how to
with actually doing it
and
i've been fascinated just an
understanding how do i help people
unleash more of their potential that
already exists
and a lot of people may have heard you
know they say that
we only use five to ten percent of our
brain that's not true we use a hundred
percent of our brains capacity neural
networks every moment of every day
but
the potential to use more
is there and so our researchers at
neurogym really are uncovering how to
take the best information from the world
of neuropsychology neuroscience
and give it to everyday people so they
can say okay how do i overcome my fear
of not being good enough my fear of not
being smart off my fear of
being embarrassed or ridiculed or
ashamed or fear of
failure or fear of success these are all
psychological issues that everybody
feels but very few people understand
when i feel that what do i do about it
so that i can unlock more of my
potential so i can actually take more
action first on the things i already
know
that i could be and should be doing but
i'm not
and next on the behaviors that i could
be taking to achieve my success easier
and faster and that's really my my
passion is is helping people unlock that
amazing potential within i was taught
the law of attraction you know i was 23
24 years old
um also at a real estate conference they
were talking about this law of
attraction thing that there's this
energy everything's made up of energy i
am energy you are energy and my thoughts
you know create this resonance between
what i attract and what i don't i'm like
oh god i like that
you know
i want to attract more of the good stuff
right
um
and so i i i bought in like i bought
into stuff that just made sense to me
but then i was a voracious student i
want to understand how
like explain to me how it works like if
somebody tells me visualize i go why
like how does it work like you asked me
to visualize like
why does it work like why should i
invest my time on that versus something
else if you're asking me to
use affirmations like how specifically
why how does it work
if you're asking me to emotionalize well
what's happening in me that tell me i
need to create these false senses of
feelings
i want to know why it works
the law of goya is is simply get off
your ass so if you if you
if you if you think and you believe and
you emotionalize you visualize
and you create your plan
for how am i actually going to achieve
this so what do i need to do when am i
going to do it how specifically how am i
going to
tweak it measure it and iterate it so
that i'm consistently making progress i
learned the value of progress versus
perfection
none of my mentors ever had me focus on
perfection
they had me focus on progress to just
keep getting better little incremental
gains every day every week every month
every quarter and even when you move
backwards a couple of steps what's the
progress that you made in what you
learned
so i was taught that failure is an
opportunity to learn
and i was also taught to
disassociate me being a failure from
failing when you start talking about my
brain
it's an organ it's like your heart is an
organ you can speed up your heart you
can slow down your heart you can
you know speed up the brain waves in
your brain you can slow them down you
can tune in you can tune out yeah we
haven't been given the user's manual for
the most powerful tools we're aware of
that's right
and so the great news you know i know
you being an athlete and a successful
businessman you have discipline you
cannot
you can't achieve responsibility results
without some kind of discipline
and so we know that there's some
fundamental truths to achieving success
and every successful person will tell
you you know and jim rohn is i know you
you love generally so you either pay the
price of discipline or you pay the price
of regret discipline weighs ounces
regret weighs tons that's good but the
the thing is can you teach discipline
the answer is yes
how you have to have a willing
participant and if the participants
reason why
is big enough if they know i want to
achieve x
and the reason why the motive for their
action motivation the motive for their
action
is a reason beyond just themselves
chances are they will do more
to achieve that success than if it was
just left up to their own but there are
some people that are born
you know with incredible drive they just
have this insatiable drive and they'll
just i'll do whatever it takes
for the things that i want
and there's other people that want
things but they just don't have this
insatiable drive
and this is where you know i as much as
i hated school i love to use schools and
analogy yeah in the game of life whether
it's health wealth relationships career
business spirituality fun experiences
you have to decide what level of the
game do i want to play at
is it the great school level the
kindergarten level the high school level
the university level the pro level
because each one of those levels
requires a totally different mindset and
totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro you will never
make as a pro business person you'll
never make it as a pro husband or wife
or athlete or musician you just never
will so just get used to that if you're
not prepared to pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude and the talent now
we're tired but there's some real
potential here
and what we don't know is you know
what's in your heart like what is the
fire that stirs you that that you wake
up saying i will do this even when i
don't feel like it i will do whatever it
takes to overcome my temptation for
mediocracy my temptation for excuses my
temptation for
reasons and circumstances to hold me
back i won't allow those to be in my way
and if you have that within you you'll
achieve whatever you choose right and so
the question you asked before is how do
you develop that start small yeah start
small
so if you
don't have discipline show to your show
yourself that you can give yourself one
command in one follow-through so you
know what
right now i'm going to get up i'm going
to do two push-ups
right now not not like later now can you
give yourself a simple command one sit
up right now i'm going to go get a glass
of water you start with something
ridiculous i learned many years ago
reduce it to the ridiculous
so for reduce it to the ridiculousness i
start i said can you do that
great will you
because that's the difference right
there
is that's the razor's edge the people
who can will you will you yeah great
when
now now yeah right so if you develop
that skill and
specifically from a brain plasticity a
neuroplasticity perspective as soon as
you do that you give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern that you can
give yourself a command and take action
now that may just be one time
well what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your computer
and every hour like if you were if my
computer was open i'd have um every hour
it would say it's 12 o'clock it's one
o'clock and i take 60 seconds
just to be in control of my mind
60 i don't care where i stop what you're
doing stop take six breaths just get it
just get centered am i on track am i off
track am i doing something i shouldn't
be doing versus a high impact activity
that i need to be doing every hour i've
trained myself to just reset
i didn't always do that so i just
started with
one a day right
then two sure then three then it was
working so well i said great let's do
this every hour the first thing that you
have to ask is what are your highest
values
so for me for example my number one
highest value is god my number two value
is my health my number three value is my
family my number four value is
contribution to the lives of others my
number fifth value is fun
so every day
when i wake up
i think about what am i doing today to
connect with god for me
just for me it doesn't have to be you
know it's not religious it's just for me
then what do i need to do every day to
make sure that i'm healthy what i need
to do every day to make sure that my
family and my dear close friends are
part of my family that i have the
relationship that's rich
then contribution how do i use my my
passion my gifts my my stories my things
i've not done well things i have done
how do i share that with the world
and in doing that i feel good
and then i have to have fun
and so if i do those five things every
day
then at the end of every day
i've had a great day
and if you have a lot of great days then
you end up with a really great life
and that doesn't mean that you don't
have ups and downs and things that don't
work and trouble that happens and things
that come up but if you keep your focus
on what's important
then the rest of the stuff is really
inconsequential
and there isn't a hundred different
things you have to do
there's two or three things in each one
of the areas that's important to you
that when you do those every day
you're so far ahead of the curve i want
to separate like behaviors and emotions
so usually when people say they're
having they're having a bad day sure
certain things may have gone wrong or
something that they tried to do you know
didn't work out
all information and experiences are
processed at the non-conscious brain
first and then it gives rise to
something we call a feeling
so emotions are processed
non-consciously the electrical and
chemical
reaction to that is called a feeling
so when i'm not feeling
the way that i want to feel
i don't focus on the feeling i focus on
the cause the neuroelectrical charge
that's occurred in my brain
and in most cases
it's something that you're doing to
interpret an event that's causing the
neuroelectrical signal
causing the feeling
so in meditation for example why do you
meditate
well obviously it's great for a whole
host of of health reasons whether it's
it's less stress less you know lower
blood pressure
less cortisol release etc but the one
thing meditation does more than anything
else
is it gives you the ability to have a
pause of awareness
so that you
sense
what's happening at the non-conscious
level right
and what's happening outside of you
so when somebody behaves a certain way
it's processed at the non-conscious
level gives rise to your conscious mind
for you to
respond
and so when something happens i like to
be able to check in
so that i don't react and i have the
ability to respond
and if you do that enough
through mindfulness being aware just
being aware of exactly what's going on
then you have fewer and fewer of those
times
so you know
something happened last week i was in a
hotel room and i spilled some water on a
shirt that i needed um for a wedding
that we were going to
and my wife was off
she was going off deep and i was just
calm yeah
and she goes aren't you worried about
this
will it help
right but
no let's just figure out what to do the
accident already happened did you know
that some of the most recent studies on
setting goals and writing them out or
typing them out on your computer will
actually increase your chances of
achieving those goals by up to 42
percent
why well as soon as you put the energy
to writing out your goals and getting
clarity you're giving your brain the
instruction that this is what's
important to you this is what you want
to achieve so don't be like all the
other people where they have goals and
dreams and they hope and pray for it to
work
be the type of person who sets her goals
or his goals in writing and then focus
on that every day and you'll achieve
more of your goals beautiful thing about
the time that we're living in now
is we can share knowledge
and experiences
and anybody with a you know a phone an
ipad or a smartphone or an android or a
computer
anywhere in the world in the kalahari
desert in antarctica can get access
and get inspired it's the best ideas in
the world yeah to get the best ideas in
the world but to see that
we're no different none of us are
different the illusion
is that we're different because we're
comparing who we are
compared to the person that we're
listening to or learning from or we're
seeing the gap
and the gap
is what causes us to be uncomfortable
but if we remember
we're all spiritual we're all made from
the exact same thing
you know if you think about the human
body it's made of hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen carbon
helium there's there's elements but we
came from the furnaces of stars
you can't have carbon
okay in the human body that didn't come
from the inside of a star
helium and hydrogen is what the big bang
was initially made up of
and then as all the gases coalesced and
created stars and then galaxies
we became
our flesh and blood and everything that
we became the organism has come from the
universal intelligence that's why we're
all connected and that's where we all
have the same abilities different skills
different knowledge but the same
abilities to become
all of the ideas
goals and dreams that we have
and so we just have to say that is what
i want to trade my life for
and even though i don't know how even
though i may not feel totally
comfortable or confident or i'm lacking
certainty
let's get let's get on the path
and then we can change the world
together let's say you know you and i
are buddies we want to start a business
or we have a business come on let's
crush it all right let's do this thing
let's triple our income this year let's
make 30 more net revenues let's travel
the world let's live this lifestyle
that's amazing and we get excited right
so we go oh yeah oh my god that's great
let's do this high fives all around
dopamine's release we feel great we
shared with our friends we release
oxytocin so we bonded oh my god i love
you and you love me and we feel great
we're going to conquer the world
and that happens all the time
but let's say
that underneath the hood
there's
a fear of
i'm not smart enough
or i'm not good enough
or what if i fail
and i embarrass myself what if i succeed
and i can't maintain it what if i'm
ridiculed because i try so hard and my
friends will laugh at me
there are fifty five zero
different types of fears
that are almost in everybody's memory
bank that gets brought up to the surface
and when the fear circuit lights up
which is bam
automatically within either moments
hours or days when you start realizing
holy what is it going to really take to
double or triple my income and and to
take the time off that i want as soon as
that happens
when the fierce circuit lights up
then the system the the neuroelectrical
chemical system floods with epinephrine
cortisol and norepinephrine what is that
those are just three of the hundred
chemicals in the brain
that are part of the stress response
system whenever
you and i
and everybody watching or listening
thinks about or feels
that there is
danger potential pain whether it's
emotional pain like being embarrassed or
ashamed or financial pain like not being
able to have enough money to pay for my
food or for my burger for my cocktails
or for my rent or my car or my airline
ticket if there is real or imagined
possibility of
discomfort pain
the brake on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can
give us this motivation the motive for
action to go forward but we have to
temper it
with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the sensation
in our body called a feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear
all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person
that has not been trained
feels fear
and puts the brake on
and goes and retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either
they may be genetically wired to
understand feeling fear and doing it
anyway turning their fear into fuel but
that's not the majority of people that's
why 90 plus percent of people fail and
stay in that position but you can take
that fuel that hypersensitive rocket
fuel i call it and utilize it to
actually motivate you faster further
than you ever got before yeah
fascinating systems if you don't know
how to use them too bad it's like not
knowing that a gun has got bullets in it
and you pull the tree the holy just blew
my brains out
not that you'd be able to you know say
that you they'd be like game over but
ignorance is not your friend when it
comes to neurochemistry if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it it's right
there next to me go click it there
continue to believe and i'll see you
there